[Music]
well thank you very much
I'm glad you announced the title of this
talk because are you sure you're all at
the right talk when I walked in I assume
that this must be somebody else's
because the title and what I've been
asked to talk about frankly is so vague
and grandiose that I thought that hardly
anybody would turn up economists people
who don't know what they're talking
about by definition talking about a
subject which nobody knows what they're
talking about by definition uncertainly
so I'm frankly rather surprised that
there are so many of you here and having
said that I may disappoint you because
I'm actually going to try to talk about
things that are a little bit more
concrete and specific than might be
implied by that rather vague title
firstly I'm going to talk about what I
assumed is the subject that everybody
really wants to discuss at this festival
but dare not amend it dare not mention
its name to speak its name
namely the economics of brexit I will
then in deference to the organizers
broaden it and generalize it a little
bit more or quite a bit more to talk
about why I think we are in a period of
extraordinary instability and
unpredictability in our understanding
not of economics as a theoretical
discipline but how the economy works and
thirdly and most importantly how that
interacts with our political system
we're again looking all over the world
but right here in Britain
we're euro unfortunately right in the
cockpit of it right now we are clearly
in a period of enormous political
uncertainty and turmoil as well but let
me begin with the specific and obviously
that will then loop back to talking
about where we are with the brexit
politics of today
literally today after the resignation of
the Prime Minister yesterday I'm gonna
talk off the top of my head but the one
part that I couldn't remember is what
the specific description of this talk
was in the program the essay question is
current political uncertainty affecting
the economy in ways that we cannot yet
see so I'll start by talking about that
rather specifically in the context of
Britain over the over the last few years
and in the years ahead because that's
obviously been a big theme of our
political discourse our since June 2016
the referendum the claim is that nothing
has really changed as a result of the
brexit referendum of the fact that
Britain is almost certainly going to be
leaving the European Union and therefore
all the predictions that were made
during the referendum campaign by those
those people I would say I was going to
say those of us so let me repeal reveal
to you exactly where I stand are all the
predictions that were made by those of
us who believe that it was a serious
mistake a very bad mistake to leave the
European Union could be completely
dismissed as a some kind of fantastic
project fear that is a classic example
of what was described in the rubric the
economics of uncertainty it is not the
economic results are not yet visible or
not yet fully visible to the naked eye
if you like to the general public of
something that has happened now the
evidence is actually if you look at it
closely and if you're an economist is
pretty clear that already
even though brexit hasn't happened
already the anticipation of brexit has
actually had a very significant effect
on the British economy and in fact
strangely enough that effect almost
uncannily in line with the predictions
that were made during the project fifth
period and according to most members of
our government and probably our future
prime minister have been totally and
utterly contradicted by events the fact
is that the predictions that were made
and I've got a few charts just
just lighten us up the main prediction
that was made before the brexit
referendum and the scariest one if you
like was that the average family the
mean family in in the UK would lose
something that mean household would lose
something like 4,500 to 5,000 pounds in
purchasing power per year as a result of
the most extreme form of rec said namely
the total rupture with Europe and
membership under WTO rules which is now
pretty much the official policy not just
of the extreme of the Conservative Party
but of all the leadership contenders in
the Conservative Party and that is the
prediction that is said to have been
totally refuted by events now there was
a second prediction which was refuted
which was the idea that there would be a
recession immediately after the brexit
vote now that didn't happen there was a
big fall in certain parts of the country
there was really a collapse and for
example in property prices especially in
London Southeast about as big as the one
that occurred in 2008-2009 the financial
crisis but there wasn't a generalised
recession ah and that was a prediction
crucially that was only made by the Bank
of England on the basis of short-term
economic forecasting which has never
worked and incidentally economic
forecasters have never correctly
predicted recession over the last 45
years
the IMF did a study they identified
something like 350 recessions
identifiable recessions around the world
in different countries and they found
that there was not a single case in
which the the conventional economic
forecasts used by central bankers for
predicting what's going on in the next 6
to 12 months predicted that recession as
as much as a year ahead so the fact that
they failed to predict a recession is
not surprising it's absolutely it's
absolutely part par for the course but
the really significant are a forecast
that were made before before the
referendum was this idea that our living
standards would
all dramatically by as I say 4,500 or as
much as 5,000 pounds per household as a
result of the most extreme form of
Rexton WTO membership now you'll say of
course that hasn't happened you know
maybe living standards have fallen a bit
for some people but they certainly
haven't collapsed in that way ah but
then those of you who might you who you
might be trying to anticipate what what
I say will say well the excuse that I'm
going to give is well after all bricks
it hasn't happened it's just the
anticipation of brexit that is partly
the explanation but that's not really
the explanation or excusive like the
real explanation is that that was a
forecast of what would happen over a
period of 15 years after brexit and this
is and and that was because this was
based these forecasts which were not
just made by the Treasury in Bank of
England but by international
institutions and so on we're not just
we're not just trying to predict what is
going to happen in the next month or the
quarter or year they were trying to
understand what would happen to the
structure of the British economy as a
result of the rupture between Britain
and its largest and also crucially
geographically its closest our trading
partners now that is the kind of
economics is often compared with to
weather forecasting and rather
unfavorably and rightly so because we're
the forecasting has now become quite an
accurate science now what we know where
the forecasting is that it's pretty good
at predicting what will happen in the
next week or so it's also very good at
predicting at least I believe most
people I suspect in this room believe
structural changes such as climate
change you know what will happen to the
climate in 30 years 50 years 100 years
where it's very poor just like economics
isn't telling you what the weather will
be like in January or January 25th next
year even in comparison with the average
weather forger in January we have no
idea where the January next year is
going to be colder or warmer than next
January and the way economics is the
same we can predict with great accuracy
what will happen next week or next month
you know I can guarantee you this
gonna be a recession and there's not
going to be a boom in the next three
months we have no idea really what's
going to happen in the next year or two
or not or no accurate idea but by
thinking about the changes in the
structure of the economy and
productivity in the competitiveness of
different industries we can make pretty
pretty convincing predictions or
analysis of how an economy will change
over a period of 10-15 years
now the interesting thing about that
forecast of 5,000 pound loss of
purchasing power to the average
household as a result of the most
extreme form of BRICS it is that was the
annual impact of leaving the EU on
Britain after 15 years if you translate
that into the decrease in GDP of
national income per head that translates
into a decrease of about 7 to 1/2 to 8
percent in GDP which is about the same
as 5000 pounds per household and you
might say well that hasn't happened of
course it hasn't happened that's over a
15 year period for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts in ideas her III TV
you